Speaker 1: Okay. Let's get back
to people waiting to chat on
discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's go next to our friend Isa from London.
Isa, welcome back to the program.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. How's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well.
Speaker 2: Um, you know, I was thinking
that loads of gun owners in the US, they say
that one of the reasons they want to own weapons
is to protect themselves from an overly intrusive
government. Yes, like a tyrannical government. Um,
so I don't know too much about this, but I was
wondering if, say, if the US government decided
to, uh, like, launch an attack on this population,
wouldn't they use military technology? That,
that would be, it would be meaningless
to use rifles against that kind of stuff.
Speaker 1: That's my opinion as well. Yeah.
And this has been brought up before, which is
if the you know, and it's funny because
many of the same people that say that love
having the biggest, most powerful military. So
they simultaneously are like, we need our military
to have all the best, most powerful stuff. And
also, if it becomes tyrannical, we need to have
our assault rifles to protect ourselves. Which,
number one, wouldn't really even be useful because
the government has such overwhelming force. But
also, if you suspect that that may happen with the
government, why would you want them to have such
a powerful army like it's both idiotic and also
contradictory? It doesn't make any sense.
Speaker 2:
Yeah. Yeah, good point. I agree. I think it's, um,
it's a bit odd how, uh, loads of American gun
owners feel like, uh, their sense of freedom is,
is tied into being able to own firearms.
Speaker 1: Yes. And not only their sense of
freedom. Their sense of identity.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right. Well,
thank you very much for the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. There's
Isa from London. Always great to hear from
our friends on the other side of the pond.